hey how's it going bros my name is so I
made a tweet saying that I'm gonna
release season two of scare PewDiePie if
it gets a hundred thousand retweets
because as some of you know scare
PewDiePie the show that I worked on for
about a month got canceled because I'm a
Nazi but the show is still there the
show is still out there it's ready to go
and I'm just sitting on it I'm not
supposed to obviously but it feels right
it feels it feels needed because so many
people worked on it and it just seems
fair that instead of YouTube Just
canceling and throwing away the show you
guys can at least watch and enjoy it so
I know I'm probably gonna get in trouble
for this but I I think it's it's it
seems fair to do and I really I really
really hope that you guys are going to
enjoy it so without further ado
I can't believe I'm saying this please
enjoy episode one of scare PewDiePie
season two
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
you scared me what the hell man it's a
prank
prank bro
you got pranks is this scary PewDiePie
season two this is scare PewDiePie
season two episode one this is not the
third one oh my God
foreign
good morning
and I'm going to be scaring PewDiePie
myself this time are you ready let's go
oh
I don't know what to do okay we've been
filming this video and he's like
like super scared but now I'm really
gonna scare him
hey Felix
YouTube have uh demonetized the whole
Channel
how do you know I just checked see the
AdSense is unlinked
it's a prank bro
hey bro
get the prank bro
thank you
that was the joke
yeah no obviously I can't I can't leak
the show it is a shame the fact that
it's all done it's all filmed it's all
ready it's just sitting there hey and
now I think that it's been like a couple
weeks since I became a Nazi looking at
it now when the dust is kind of settled
it's like why why is this happen it just
seems so stupid uh especially the fact
that other people who worked on there
because so many people worked on the
show their work doesn't get to be out
there because of some stupid [__]
jokes like it seems
almost insane uh and it's a shame it's a
damn shame uh Jack was a huge part of
the show he was going to be like the
villain of the show and he had a big
involvement and it was a lot of fun
going on between me and two we had a
guest in every single episode so 10 10
other YouTubers and and personalities
were guests Ethan and hila from H3 who
are Jewish by the way
you [__] Jewish people over by canceling
the show like good job good job you did
it cam was going to be on the show
obviously Mark eight Mark eight uh Pig
testicles
and which you will never see the light
of day can cinnamon toast Ken got dipped
in [__] for nothing there's just so much
[__] that we did that month and it's ah
I hate it I hate it but this is how it
is [__] happens uh what are you gonna do
look looking back as well when we filmed
that show it was literally the worst
month I I actually I don't want to be
over dramatic but it seemed like it was
definitely one of the worst months I
ever experienced filming that show not
because I didn't enjoy filming the show
I had a such a blast it was such an
amazing thing and fun thing to do I
upload videos every single day and for
me to do that and film a show at the
same time was a [__] nightmare it was
the worst idea I've ever had to think
that I could do that and then when I
realized I couldn't do that along with
all these other things happening as well
at the same time I was [__] depressed
like it was driving me crazy I you saw
the video I'm [__] crying like a
little baby it's so stupid I just need
to finish what I'm doing here in L.A
I need to put myself first so
disappointed
at least I don't have to do season three
oh yeah I hope you're not mad at me for
lying to you I'm sorry I think if
there's one thing out of all all these
things happening that I would like to
see changed it is the fact that the show
should come out I really really think it
should and hopefully in the future
you'll be able to watch it but until
then
you'll just have another shitty YouTube
video you're welcome